yeah well while i pull it up do you want
to explain what's happening with uh with
his brandon shobs new special so brendan
schaub who was uh joe rogan's one of joe
rogan's toys
um
he's uh he just recently came out with a
speaking special
new special what he's got called you'd
be surprised now it's sitting right now
at a whopping 2.9 on imdb
2.9 folks
2.9
brandon chavez 2.9
on imdb now
what is this that you posted uh this
let's help brendan out letter
from our ceo now who's seen i'm sorry
it's now up to 3.2 uh because of this
thing you're about to point out okay so
what who posted this so brendan schaub
uh i guess
co-owns some kind of
cbd oil
shill company they all do they all got
something yeah
uh so brendan schaub
um
i guess his partner
decided that uh well i don't know how it
worked but i do know this i do know that
brendan chaub put a special out called
you'd be surprised it was a 2.9 out of
10 on imdb
everybody's been [ __ ] on it and it's
not just people because the only people
i know that hate brendan schaub are
us and the red bar audience i don't know
anybody that really finds him like
particularly offensive enough to go
after i've never found them funny but
but i mean like offensive to their
senses like nobody's like oh i [ __ ]
hate brendan chop so he sort of coasted
through all this time by being just so
unremarkable that nobody really picked
up on him but he came out with this
special
it has been universally [ __ ] on everyone
hates it so red bar picked up on it and
uh i saw in their group that it wasn't
doing well but i looked at the amount of
votes
it's not mike david's fans that made
this thing plumb like it's it's a 2.9
with like almost a thousand votes on
yeah no that means that's legit that is
people going ooh this was terrible i'm
gonna go give it one star
uh so the other day this came out this
is the guy that i guess owns the
actually owns the the company the cbd
oil company because you know like the
rogans you know rogan's not showing up
to board meetings for on it like you
know what i mean of course not slapped
his name on it and he gets big fat
checks uh this is sort of the deal with
brendan so he's got the cbd oil thing so
this apparently is the ceo of the cbd
oil company
shilling for shops special on reddit and
begging people
to uh here i'll just read it it says uh
let's show our support for brendan as
you all know my business partner brendan
schaub debuted his comedy special on
showtime earlier this month you all
showed up in force when my company ran a
sale in honor of the debut today i'm
asking our customers and the entire the
fighter and the kid army
they say army
you're not a you're not a nation-state
yucky
uh the fighter and the kid army to help
us support this special today through
the end of the week if you follow the
link below and leave a kind review the
kind of review
brendan deserves for you'd be surprised
you will receive a one-time coupon for
50 off your entire pure spectrum order
they're bribing so the company that
brandon shall bones a piece of
and i don't think the ceo i think
brandon went to him and was like i need
a [ __ ] bell out here so they're
giving 50 off their products
they're giving [ __ ] away basically
just to try to
combat the bad reviews on imdb
do you want to see we're going to play
the thing you played you want to see
this is a little promo clip that's on
youtube i bet it's good uh so it's a
trailer so we're allowed to play this so
let's uh this is for his special i
haven't seen this this is 100 haven't
seen this
so i'm doing a i'm doing back up a bit
here should we give it time i just can't
become a pothead overnight
i need to talk to some experts
so i'm doing this i'm doing a podcast i
need to talk to actually speak his big
tongue like there's a big tongue in his
mouth or something yeah he's got a good
i think he's got like an underbite type
thing yeah okay but
let's actually try to give it a chance i
really i haven't seen this so this is
100 as we haven't seen this well joey
diaz joe rogan eddie bravo attila
i'm sorry i don't mean to i know why po
please play the clip
you are using the coattails you rode
to do a stand-up bit i want to point out
this is the trailer this is the trailer
yes special yes he has name dropped
eddie bravo joey diaz and joe rogan in
the first 11 seconds yeah i mean
immediately
and by the way that is if you go to imdb
most of the bad reviews you see on
reddit and everywhere it's people saying
it's just name dropping in stories like
people saying basically like yeah if i
met brendan schaub at a bar
this would be kind of cool right but
it's not a special there's no jokes
well other boys my recent discovery of
marijuana can help with my brain this is
what happens next joey diaz guess what
happened next
does he really talk like that like a
[ __ ]
to me a gummy death star
it's a rhinoceros tranquilizer i had no
freaking clue i had no idea
and joey diaz goes [ __ ] sucker just
[ __ ] half my guess beat the whole
thing on the [ __ ] pluto
he doesn't that's all though terrible
that's a terrible joey diaz when does
joey diaz ever yell like that never it's
always like hey kid don't move
take yourself a [ __ ] you ain't a real
[ __ ] potted you have somebody stars a
[ __ ] death kid you take like [ __ ]
three of those
you know what i'm saying you go find
some like girl you [ __ ] eat her ass
out like real [ __ ] you know on the
beach
where you get the [ __ ] well you got
like [ __ ] sand
in a rest crack and you [ __ ] get it
in your teeth and [ __ ] you know what i'm
[ __ ] saying kid
you get it hey where's the [ __ ] fat
jewel guy i always got on my show
relax joey pluto
chill man
mama didn't raise no queen right the
whole goddamn star
i've never seen sheer panic on joe
rogan's face before he's like this [ __ ]
why blind look over at eddie bravo's
face he's like this
why is it
so this guy's special so they made a
coke logic cartoon for his special yeah
apparently
and the whole thing is just
i'm going to tell you about these three
guys that are way cooler than me
let me tell you about these three guys
that are you know what this is like
ringo starr telling a story about the
rest of the beatles this is like the
show entourage if it was told from the
point of view of turtle oh
[Laughter]
wrong way
have fun bro
imagine if this show entourage was about
turtle this is
this is joe rogan's fault joe rogan's
the one that told brendan schaub he
should be doing stand up
this is his fault
then the podcast started
i didn't say a single word in three
hours not one word in three hours not
one word it was the greatest three hours
those boys ever experienced weed man
you ever been so high before you forget
what language you speak i no i
i've been out of my mind on drugs
and i still shockingly brendan i i speak
english very weird i might not speak it
well when i'm on drugs but
you still know what i'm saying what a
terrible joke he this is
this is my material from 2007. danny
saint this is virgil telling nwo stories
oh my god perfect reference that's what
it is perfect reference
i was so high i was so high
how high were you honestly brendan
schaub isn't even like the vincent of
the nwo though he's more like the
disciple
this is bad remember disciple yes it was
which is like the 18th gimmick of brutus
the barber beefcake
it brings like throw after the
conversation
like in what language though what is
that what is that
is that french [ __ ] speak french no
it wasn't french though it's not this is
no i'm i'm not listen i i'm not going
into this purposely not laughing buckley
saying this is hack open mic that's what
i mean this was me
in 2007
remember when i started comedy
this is 2007.
this is my 2007. this is
you
coming up with a new hour and working it
is this isn't this doesn't feel like am
i right wrong doesn't feel like a
finished product it's an open mic or
this is at least
a gig on the road
where you go all right i'm gonna do like
i'll do like 20 minutes of solid [ __ ]
but i'm gonna throw like i'm gonna you
know you gotta throw like 10 minutes in
that's why louie does the road all the
time he's trying to work that right but
like
this is just
[ __ ] horrible this is not a this is
not an album
stay quiet man i'm just gonna stay quiet
this isn't good man the podcast finally
wraps my high brain goes oh [ __ ] that
did not go well my man
don't let your buddies know how [ __ ]
up you are just do a cool exit and get
the hell out the building oh i know
i've been watching a bunch of game of
thrones lately yeah
so joey eddie and ron go hey man you
sure you're good
am i ever
me lord
no don't
let that sit
no just let it let it cook
but then what was the reference
that he was referencing from game of
thrones what does it have to do with
making an exit
in there
tweet man
i
i want to make an announcement here from
the bottom of my heart uh
i'm gonna quit weed i don't want to
smoke weed anymore no i
i don't want to be i don't want to do i
don't want to do youtube anymore either
though
because it's i don't want to do anything
that brendan shout does
so i am not i'm not going to do any more
youtube shows steroids i'm not going to
smoke any marijuana yeah i'm going to
quit steroids okay go more steroids
um
well prednisone i'm
uh
and then uh i'm never gonna get dumped
uh by ronda rousey so there's you know
those a lot of things
are you gonna be the filling host
whenever joe rogan needs to just talk
and needs a body a warm body in the
chair
because that's what he is he's the warm
body whenever rogan's like i kind of
want to talk about me but i don't want a
cool guest on i want to make sure it's
about me so i'm going to put a hot body
in the chair and uh who it's him and
who's the other one eddie bravo
there's one more though uh
brian um brian callan yeah brian there
it is i know yeah right so those are the
people he has sit in brian calling is
another one that's like literally human
water yeah he's like he's a human glass
of water yeah there's nothing offensive
about it it's not
oh and bro and brian redman i don't hate
brian callan he's kind of funny we don't
know but he's i don't hate him he's like
a glass of water yeah he's just there
it's you know you go
ah i needed that but there's no reward
no nothing yeah you're like well you
know there's water at least i'm not
thirsty
that's what he brings
brian callan is at least i'm not thirsty
you know you know what he is i just
figured it out brian callan
is like
pepsi
at a restaurant
it's nobody wants it there but you'll
have it if that's what it's so
unoffensive that you're not going to get
angry it's not rc culture that's exactly
he's pepsi at a restaurant or a bar
where you go yeah can i get a coke and
they're like we have pepsi and you're
like
yeah i guess whatever spring black
liquid that has carbonation
i get my car might as well be in the
starship enterprise i'm like okay i was
messing with my ac unit for 30 minutes
i'm like no that's not it that's not it
it's not it man
finally i get started found myself going
down that 405 highway 17 imagine doing
pot stories in 2019
on show time this was a showtime special
hot stories dude i couldn't bro i was
driving dude i was like man am i
speeding but then i looked at my
speedometer and i'm doing like 10 miles
an hour oh
is he gonna do that that old gag just
everything
miles an hour happy as [ __ ]
i went through stages the next stage i
got super paranoid i started my mirrors
every three seconds i'm like what the
[ __ ] is happening right now man what am
i doing what am i doing i thought
there's no jokes here
no there's not again he's just talking
this isn't and you're not even like no
but you know what
that's unfair because there's some
comics that could go up there and are
very funny and tell good stories you
know what i mean like
uh norm mcdonald if you ever watch nor
mcdonald's like show like the youtube
one
that's a guy who'll just sit there and
he could talk for an hour and be really
funny and tell you good one of my
favorite episodes of the norm show was
when norm was on with super dave
uh before that just those two people
like he's not even telling an
interesting story
i had a cousin that was a pothead and
told these stories that was really never
funny to me
[ __ ] cool man
there were werewolves in it
dude you know no dude we got to address
this why is he dressed like a [ __ ]
persian nightclub owner
look at him tight little pants
he's like he's dressed like
if pete davidson was going to a wedding
he's okay that's good he's dressed like
when your aunt picks you up from school
why did why is all right well you know
how like when you smoke weed sometimes
and you drive and then there's
werewolves in your car this never
happened to me
it's never happened to me in my life
he's telling a weed story from the
perspective of a man who's never smoked
weed
oh
brendan child is dressed like an
alternate in a bowling team phase that
kicked in is what the kids refer to as
the munchies
burning shop dresses like the [ __ ] 40
year old guy that still like [ __ ]
sells pot and [ __ ] to and [ __ ] high
school girls you know what i mean
you want to come over i got ps4 it's
pretty dope
uh ps4 and xbox pretty dope but he still
uses his parents netflix account
this is good because we're gonna play
next here is them roasting people
brendan schaub looks like a guy who
still lives with his parents in his 30s
and every sunday you can see him washing
his car in the driveway
you're right
and you're just like bro but you put
that much pride into your account
balance
get up out of your parents house brandon
trout child looks like someone who dry
cleans their jeans
i know i've known people like that they
have creases in them i've known people
like that it's in ray anybody who who
dry cleans jeans should be [ __ ] shot
they should have to go in front of a
firing squad
oh [ __ ]
somebody said now look stevie said
schaub is definitely a militant bisexual
he's that clingy annoying friend in the
group that does everything he doesn't
like just to tag along
no man it's cool i love rock climbing
i do it all the time
brandon shop looks like he has two
barbed wire tattoos
looks like he has a tribal barbed wire
yes you're right like a tribal with
[ __ ] barbs
he couldn't decide brandon shot the guy
that shows up to the high school party
with four locos
yeah brendan schaub looks like a guy who
buys beer for teenagers yay
no brandon shop this guy guy who sells
beer
all right but i'm keeping 20.
brendan schaub looks like a guy who's on
a sex offender registry but is low
offending enough that he'll probably get
off at some point right right
bernie shelby looks like a guy they're
just about to take off a sex offender
yeah
he was 19 she was 17. you know i like
the whole thing
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
um
brendan child dressed as like an extra
from the beat it video
brendan shaw was dressed like a guy who
bugs you every weekend about having a
booth at amphitheater you know i got a
goo boo
good bottle service bro goodbye i'll get
you in
we only got two tables left tonight it's
friday
brendan chop is somebody who has a can
of axe body spray in his glove
compartment just in case
just in case yes
that's really funny
oh [ __ ] hey you know what mike this is
good since this is we could compare what
you can bring aaron schaub looks like a
guy who's constantly asking you hey you
know anybody that needs a stereo
installed in a car or anything like that
i'm really good
i got all the tools
jesus christ
he really is just a [ __ ] goof
i wish i had his hairline though i'll
admit yeah he has good hair there's one
thing i'm jealous of it's his hair yeah
good for he means he when he did his
steroids you took propecia with it
that's all that's what that means
um
he got he got he got busted i believe in
mma he got popped a couple times
yeah you could take if you take like
propecia
uh and there's or finn instead i believe
if you take those while you do steroids
you won't lose it kind of
counterbalances and you won't lose your
hair
uh
but yeah that's really the only way to
do it uh
but but that was a good you know
roasting so why don't why don't we watch
brandon chao
and theo vaughn the king and the sting
yeah this show
it's just and then he does the fighter
and the kid is that one with brian cowan
that's the one brian i believe yes
there's too many too many uh
this is uh this is them this is they're
roasting each other this is uh theo
vaughn and brendan chop's funniest roast
and this is great because we kind of
just did so i'm curious compared from
rogan's studio
no i i believe this is theo has his own
studio that's so i'm almost positive why
wouldn't rogan use rent out his studio
yeah because he's got it there it's just
that i don't know what it is though
because he's a billionaire and he
probably doesn't watch people touching
us that's not even that but rogan's
studio also is his gym
he also has a salt tank in there that's
his like that's his like man cave you
know everybody there he chills there all
the time like that's his home away from
home
uh
all right so you mean if rogan built a
studio that like is perfectly um
like uh tailored to his lifestyle yeah
and isn't uh
some kind of albatross around his neck
on like compound
rice right oh he bought it that's must
that must have been
it must be nice to own the building
that's probably a great investment you
know even if the show flops you have the
building
and joe rogan also does his show in his
own studio unlike jim norton who does it
in bob kelly's
so
well it's okay he also does it as
somebody else oh that's right
it's got to be terrible that you're more
famous for being a character it's like
we did the pat morita thing like pat
marina was actually spoke english very
well funny guy but he's he'll always be
remembered as mr miyagi that's what chip
chipperson is it's jim norton's mr
miyagi
and that's the thing dude is is norton
uh
he's
that chip show is starting to uh it's
starting to plateau oh yeah because
everybody's like oh [ __ ] he does this
the whole time
oh yeah and somebody's and if people who
do better than you i'd hope so he's been
in radio for [ __ ] forever 20 years i
hope he was on jay leno i hope he's more
than to show for it yes yeah he's been
doing
uh a
syndicated terrestrial radio since i was
in high school yes i'd hope he has
something to show for it i hope he's
bigger than i am i love when people do
yeah like he said
you are yeah well he's older than me and
had 20 year head start and worked for
cbs you want
uh this is uh the so sorry theo vaughn
and brendan chubb
funniest roast so this is them roasting
each other i heard you also wearing a
large from uh disneyland bro children's
lawrence you look like a college kid i
mean you got blue one that was given to
you got a purple [ __ ] skinny sweats
on these are plum those are purple bro
these aren't purple dude you look like
you're transitioning and ran out of
money
[Laughter]
you look like you look like a russian
spy who's transitioning but they don't
know exactly you already did the
transition joke you don't build on that
he's not good you don't you don't build
on that i mean theo's not great either
but no
i think he's better than he's competent
yeah yeah i think he's better than
brandon for sure
how works in [ __ ] america
so they give us this
dude no doubt you look like every gay
dude that's about to teach a dance
lesson on television that's exactly what
you look like right now i'll take that
no
dance show honestly there's a lot of
people in here you saw what we we just
did to in the last like in the last
segment to brendan is this better
because if it is i want to apologize
you got that blood gold watch dude how
many brothers how many black men and
probably black children that's what die
so you could have that watch there's no
such thing as blood gold blood diamond
it's blood diamond they don't even oh my
god guys better references guys come on
man we'll help you out why do you have a
stack of [ __ ] uh uh emergency and
coasters
yeah just in case he's very successful
from the aids that this show will give
you yeah
oh no man i don't know bro
diamonds bro dude diamonds if you put it
up tomorrow but i can hear the mayflower
coming over with a bunch of straight-ups
i'm just saying
you go in that direction i wouldn't wear
that kind of stuff man no it's not it's
not for you bro it's not for your kind
yeah then that's being that's being cool
[Laughter]
wow can't slip one by this [ __ ]
cavalier cat you gotta let the audience
know bro
and i gotta let you know they have
zero chemistry right i mean they have
and i'm not saying they don't like each
other they probably you can get along
with somebody and still have no
chemistry with them these two have
no chemistry together
brendan's child dresses like he's upside
down on a lease for a corvette
[Laughter]
right you know what i mean
that haircut doesn't exactly scream i
got a degree bro
right now and by the way theo vaughn's
haircut's when i was like dude i don't
even care it's like what i don't even
care bro
haircuts she's it's one of those where
you it's something where you would do
that for like a bit maybe one show but
like nah man this is my i don't even
care what people think dude theo vaughn
and in this clip theo vaughn looks like
a guy who got a high school girl
pregnant
and brendan schaub looks like a guy who
uh
who sells uh debt settlement services
you're right
dude i could fix your credit score right
now i'm telling you dude 100 point jump
right away right away i just need seven
hundred dollars from you
if i had to see if i had [ __ ] seven
hundred dollars and a better credit
[Laughter]
he looks like a door-to-door life
insurance salesman
he looks like a door-to-door pot
salesman yeah that's a really good point
yeah you're right my car broke down i
need some money but i got weed i want to
buy some weed for me yeah brendan schaub
looks like his dream is to finally own
that big
dispensary what's up bro
what's up bro oh my god i'll have a
second scoop of uh yams please all right
okay all right
brandon jobs dressed like he looks like
one of those puerto ricans that pretends
to have a flat tire when you pull over
to help when he robs you
you're right
[Laughter]
and i can't believe theovan has that
hair on purpose brendan schaub is a guy
who owns two cell phones
and why does theovan have ricky morton's
haircut i don't know you mean it grows
in all white trashy like that on its own
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] rock and roll
express over here
right it's it's that make brandon job
the robert gibson no seriously
these guys look like they should come
out with jim cornett you're right
okay definitely that is cafeteria grade
hair right there cafeteria lady here
piccadilly bro go
oh it's cool it's cool you wore your
[ __ ] uh matt do why do all the los
angeles com uh comics dress like this
right they all imitate one guy but i
don't know who it is not rogan cause
rogan's to rogan's credit rogan is very
much a guy who does not give a [ __ ]
what's on his body no he just wears his
free tv god bless him because that's
like honestly like if i had rogan's
money you wouldn't see me like go check
out my watches and my suits i'd probably
have an on it shirt on every day of a
different copy like i don't know
we make [ __ ] we made we have an
entire warehouse just for shirts i just
wear the [ __ ] shirts and the [ __ ] but
like him and and i gotta say i love the
guy but i'm gonna knock him here but sam
tripoli's another one there are these
guys that are like 30 something 40
something years old and they are dressed
like white pot dealers and it's
it's un
it's
unbecoming to me it's just i don't know
brendan schaub looks like he's part of
the date rape frat at every college
exactly but they they all have they're
all these guys are all sneaker heads
they're all uh hipsters all tony
hinchcliffe's another one
but like even tony hinchcliffe doesn't
at least doesn't wear like wig or [ __ ]
like these guys are all trying to be
like yo look at how [ __ ] in style i
am you're a stand-up comedian in l.a i
wouldn't call him that
but in general these i'm not talking
most stand-up comedians don't have
cauliflower here i'm not talking to him
i'm talking to every member of the death
squad you're a stand-up comedian in l.a
stop trying to be cool with your hoodies
and your sneakers bro like your [ __ ]
stop
marcos ray five dollars
brennan looks like he sells perfume at
mall chaos
exactly right we're selling cases very
self yes that's very very good
overall what the [ __ ] what is this what
is this i'm glad you wear your long
johns into this
dude these are 100 cotton yeah that's
what long johns are bro
seriously
theo vaughn's dressed like he's part of
the canadian bobsled team
messing up today this isn't you know
artificial stuff is 100 cotton dude i
swear to god this is so awkward i'd
rather see theo vaughn this is less
awkward than if theo von did a show with
tom segura
so what's up man like i [ __ ] your wife
dude like what's that about
you're all mad because i used to [ __ ]
your wife and now you're like super
pissed off about it what's up tom and
then tom's like i'm a fat guy i'm so
funny you nailed it that's pretty much
what they did did you see the clips of
that by the way have you seen
the theo vaughn theogate no so oh this
is a rabbit hole so what is it what
happened with theo so theo vaughn and
christina p
were both on uh
like real world and road rules around
the same time in the 90s
and there's this weird vibe where tom
segora and and christina p will not
acknowledge theovan's existence on any
level even when he gets brought up they
just won't acknowledge it
so the rumor is that uh tom segura hates
him because he used to [ __ ] christianity
back in the day and there's now now
people are digging through old road
rules uh
real world clips and finding like you
know the the reunion shows where they
get together and get interviewed like
they're flirting and holding hands and
[ __ ] like so yeah pretty much theo
vaughn the theories that theovonne
plowed their [ __ ] out of christina p
back in the 90s back when she was a
little more of a right ace and that's
and then
so they had uh what's his face
uh yeah it might be at work people are
saying it was a work i don't think it's
a work though um none of these people
are that smart i just put it that way
none of these people are that smart um
but uh h3 uh ethan the jewy guy he was
on uh their podcast with um
tom and christina's podcast and they
literally like he brought up theo and he
goes uh
he's like yeah theo thinks you like hate
him or something like he thought no no
that's right uh brandon schaub brought
it up and they were like all awkward and
then they had ethan klein on and ethan
kline goes what's the beef with you and
theovan like there's some kind of beef
there and then they just cut out a bunch
of the show and then it's just them
laughing
huh so i don't know if it's a bit or not
but it's they might be playing it up but
there is definitely enough evidence that
theovonne used to plow [ __ ] thompson
or his wife and he's and again it's not
a bit because
i think they kind of caught on to people
whispering about it
so they did that part as a bit because
they wanted to kind of get people like
interested in the show but i don't think
the him hating theo vaughn thing is a
bit i think they really because when
they brought it up on um
the bobby lee the the other asian guy
one of the only guys on that [ __ ] in
that little circle of people that i
adore i love bobby lee he's nut he asked
christina p about theovan and her just
her mood soured right for the rest of
the show it was very weird so something
happened he plowed uh tom segura's wife
you look like a backup dancer for
beyonce or something right now like
you're like you're going they're really
bad at burns man like they're really
really bad at them they're rehearsals
do we do every rehearsal today
do you look like you look like rehearsal
for nickelback even though they don't
have dancers
you know a joke's good when you have to
say even though they don't have his okay
you know his joke structure is really
not good you know what you look like uh
you know you look like brendan you look
like an american eagle outfitters threw
up on louis j gomez
see now that's funny
see what i did was funny
very funny what i did was funny
[Laughter]
it really does if luigi gomez dressed
from like arrow pistol instead it was
like yeah bro i don't [ __ ] do mma
it's [ __ ] stupid
bro you i you do you look basically
you're like a fat guy dude that's shaped
well you're not even really strong that
doesn't even work
ever dude yeah they're like work you
look like jared leto's side piece
whatever
like he dressed you this morning was
like those put the [ __ ] pajamas back
though not even so i can suck your dick
when i want what
you have another bite oh you do i see it
from here yeah yeah i think i do
bulldog
okay i'm sorry yang gang us i have to
read this as a very theo looks like he's
about to explain the benefits of the
12-step program
that's very good
he really does you know what's funny i
was looking at him earlier and i was
trying to think of a joke but you did it
way better like i was trying to think of
a
a recovery center guy because you really
theovon does have that look damn hey man
look there's a whole laugh after alcohol
and drugs and you're like i know but
it's a terrible life and it sounds
horrible and boring
you do sir i looked over here like this
you look like a [ __ ] you look like
bubble gum
you look like bubble gum if you got
sammy sosa's bubba gump was black guy
but yeah no bubba gump was the name of
the fish company that they started bubba
was the guy gump is forrest gump
he's he says he's saying he looks like a
restaurant mike oh [ __ ]
bro you look
horrible these these fake laughs and
stuff
dude you look like uh
like like you got uh
like you bought discount t-shirts or
something
this this guy these fake laughs and
these these little podcasts has given
this guy a
a false a false sense
of security you know what i mean you
know what these two actually false sense
of of
of thinking he's a funny guy he's not a
funny guy it's just he's surrounded by
people that are comic so he thinks he's
one
you know what he is too like i uh it's
like uh
you know these two remind me of is
remember the the two brothers from snl
it was chris parnell and jimmy fallon
and they would have like the mustaches
oh yeah yeah yeah and they were just
they were just all their jokes were
terrible and all they had was each other
to bounce off of but yeah i i agree with
the chat i i joe rogan has given brendan
shout brendan shaw but a false sense of
being funny like you have lied to this
man
he has delusions of grandeur exactly
random name he they he he thinks he's
something he's not you're not a funny
guy you weren't here look i got a good
what brendan shall looks like you ready
brendan schaub looks like somebody who
failed at mma and is now currently
failing at comedy is that a good one is
that a funny one that was actually my uh
what i said on twitter i was like wow
brendan ciao is the comedy what brendan
schaub was to mma somebody actually i
saw a pretty good meme of brendan schwab
standing in the uf uh ufc ring
and then doing stand-up and he goes
which stand-up was worse
it was [ __ ] it was [ __ ] mean
i look horrible yeah you look like a
community college mascot community
college
enunciate you punch drunk idiot dude you
look like a child bro i look like a
child yeah
do you look like hey mike imagine if
we're roasting each other and i ended
everything with bro
which would you be like bro you're
roasting me bro
bro
hey mike
you look like a stupid bird you bro
there's there are really good ones
coming in i'm going to read a few of
these shirts because go for it i would
love it i want to read our fans are
funnier jackie rose for 1999 said i
haven't supported my handsome boys in a
week or so i'm a terrible sugar mama
forgive me you're always forgetting by
the way jackie rose sent a picture of
her wearing the shirt first off she's
fine but you ruined the shirt when you
cut it down the middle cut it and then
you ruined the shirt you ruined the
shirt also i don't know
if it's the shirt that looks good or if
it's you that's making the shirt look i
think it's hard so you have to send me a
picture without the shirt without the
shirt so that that's the only way when i
then i can judge and then we'll
theo looks like he's about to explain
how nascar is really a
sport hey man it takes a lot of you know
you got to learn
how to drive the car man
rex
uh rex filipino shade these guys look
like they got uh raped in a buckle store
and from that day forward they dress
like their surroundings they got raped
in
uh i already read the the uh brendan
looks like he sells perfumer malkias
these guys are great uh kane says honest
opinion shop isn't funny because he's
too well to do you have to be more of an
anti-social degenerate to actually be
funny
uh
that not necessarily i think jim
gaffigan's funny and he's not brian
regan's not and he's funny
uh he's just not funny uh
like i guess we're done with them right
let me finish base cringe said brendan
should sue joe for humiliating him i
like that agreed 100